I'm here at london's heathrow t5 to
visit one of my favorite restaurants
playing food now in a minute when we go
behind the scenes and find out what
really goes on in this restaurant in the
busiest airport across europe the idea
behind plain foods is simple I like you
to eat incredibly well before takeoff
and one of the best-looking restaurants
anywhere in the country you come away
from that hustle bustle for the chicken
and you walk through that stunning open
bar into this elegant spacious Airy
vibrant restaurant and for me it's a
great way of taking that stress out of
that journey with a good meal I know how
precious time is I also know you've got
a plane to catch so we'll serve you
within 10 minutes and you'll be out the
door within 20 now breakfast is one of
the busiest times here at playing food
and trust me we are very proud of our
excellent menu it could be the classic
or flues breakfast or the most amazing
like what they scrambled eggs with
smoked salmon let me tell you it is the
perfect way to start your day and have
an incredible journey now another big
hit for lunch and dinner has to be the
butter chicken and it's all down to this
Tennessee man chef gonna see what you
see me you good yes very good everywhere
I go in on the New York Paris and we'll
watch the butter chicken you crazy the
phenomenon is butter chicken loveliness
how many ports of the day do this how we
do 150 for Sunday 150 a day
legendary pay rise our aim is to serve
the freshest and some of the quickest
food anywhere in this airport and Ben's
giving their common examples got beaver
California Maki roll and then we're just
gonna top it off with some crab meat and
that looks so elegance oh it's really
good for fly I'm especially when you've
got the garnish on the side so moolies
tradition service sushi to speed along
the metabolism basically when you off
the plane you feeling fresh so you're
not feeling sluggish exactly useful next
we're gonna do another raw dish tuna
tartare so inside the tuna tartare chili
garlic sesame seeds sesame oil and just
seasoned really nice of a touch of soy
sauce and then we just finish it
little bit of chili or lovely around the
dish then they look great now the
exciting part some of the customers good
job
welcome we good now the most amazing to
the touch heart for you make your roll
please enjoy
could I sleep over so I've never been a
big fan of eating heavy food on the
airplane so one of the concepts we came
up with here was a really exciting grab
and go and it is light refreshing but
more importantly it's kind of food that
you don't need to sleep in three hours
after it you enjoy it land at your
destination and you've eaten well
onboard and then for the children our
youngest autumn Matilda's put this
incredible Tilly's box of treats
together whether you're here at 5 a.m.
in the morning for breakfast or 10 p.m.
the level of warmth welcoming and
consistency from the kitchen couple that
incredible elegant service it's
breathtaking enjoy excellent thank you
now my flight leaves in 30 minutes and
what a perfect way to sit and relax
enjoy a full English breakfast so
whether you're here on business or even
on holiday trust me
t5 plain food was designed to give you
the perfect send-off
have a safe flight
you